good evening everybody and welcome to
the first meeting of this Committee of
um the new Municipal year
um I've received apologies from
um councilor Paul councilor Jorge and
councilor Carter who is the executive
member for children's services
um
we've had a couple of reports that are
for noticing
um so we have the membership of the
committee so it's nice to see some new
faces as well as some older ones I won't
say the word old because I am of a
certain age
um
the committee terms of reference are
also attached as a report
um
and can I ask are there any Declarations
of interest in any of the items on the
agenda tonight
no okay thank you
and we've also received the minutes of
the previous meeting
um are we okay to accept those for those
that were there
okay thank you
foreign
s from the public which is unusual
um
so I'm going to go through them one at a
time and we only have 15 minutes as a
rule allowed for questions so we'll keep
an eye on the time we've actually
received 14 questions which is highly
unusual as you will appreciate
um
we have
um members in fact before we start can I
ask that we do some introductions so we
all know who they are so my name is
Denise Weston I'm a broad Heath World
counselor and I chair this committee so
if I can go this way
yeah hi my name is Rob Duncan um
hi everyone I'm Sally Atkinson I'm
hi I'm Pamela Wharton director for early
health and children Trafford
evening everybody I'm Jill McGregor I'm
the corporate director for children's
services here in Trafford
hello everybody Karen samples Director
of Education for Trafford
foreign
[Music]
councilor e Parker for sale Central Ward
councilor Shirley Proctor from lostock
and Barton Ward
councilor Joanne Bennett
councilor Emma Hurst from Ultra
councilor David atten from Ghost Hill
and Cornbread Ward and a chair of course
scrutiny and ex-officio on this
committee
councilor Sean Ennis timpley Center
award
Harry Calhan governance officer and I'll
be taking over Alex as the governance
officer for this committee moving
forward
and Alex Murray governance officer okay
just for the benefit of those new
members these two guys are here to keep
me in order and make sure I don't do
anything wrong so I hope you will enjoy
the committee what I will say is please
don't be afraid there is no such thing
as a silly question in scrutiny so
please I want to see hands up and ask
questions
um we've all come from different
viewpoints and different walks of life
so really interested to get your input
and that's what we're here for and these
officers absolutely love your questions
okay so I'm going to start with the
questions from the public
um so the first question is how many
tribunals appeals were there in 2022
including numbers that went to a hearing
and cost to the council including staff
time in defending those tribunals so I
don't know if that's a figure you'd have
to hand yeah yeah thank you chair
um we can certainly give you the numbers
um in terms of the staff time and cost
that's something we'll have to take away
because it's a more detailed piece of
work but we can provide the feedback to
to the person that submitted the
question so 11 were lodged
um and the council's position upheld was
Zero
thank you
um so how many of those tribunals in
2022 was the outcome that the tribunal
agreed with the local authorities
so so it was Zero yeah okay
and how many tribunal appeals have been
submitted in 2023 so far they've been
five so far so is that from April or
from January from January
okay
um
could you tell us the number of
complaints about the ehcp team and
process to date in
2023. again that's something we'll
provide separately if that's okay
because it will require some contact
with the ice team
um to determine that that number thank
you thank you
um
so could you tell us the number of ehcp
case managers and their current caseload
yeah we have one service manager
and we have one senior EHC coordinator
um but we have 11.49 coordinators and
their case loads are roughly between 220
and 280 EHC plans
okay and could you tell us the number of
vacancies currently in the team yeah
there are none
we've actually had some temporary
additionality added to the team and that
and that's something that we'll continue
to review
thank you
um
on average how many ehcp needs
assessment requests are there per month
um certainly so we've done it from 2022
because that was kind of a complete year
if you like
um the lowest was 28 and that
interestingly was during the summer
holidays that tends to be the month of
August the highest was 62 and that's
between June and July so the average is
roughly around 40. okay thank you
um
could you tell us the number of children
and young people with ehcps without a
school place for September yeah we we
had to go back and just clarify some
additional information on that just in
terms of the time period or a specific
cohort of young person
um and the person who submitted the
question is come back with with what
that means so we will require additional
time to provide that okay thank you
um could you tell us the number of
children and young people who do not
have any hcp naming their new school
stroke College placement for September
and again we sought clarification and
we'll come back
okay how long are the wait times for
health assessments occupational therapy
autism assessments mental health
assessments physiotherapy assessments
are they completed in time for the draft
ehcps to be sent to families
I mean obviously this involves Health
Partners so that's something that we
will have to seek information from
Health Partners and provide that at a
later date
thanks and how how does the send
partnership board ensure it hears the
voices of young people with special
needs including those who are non-verbal
um this is something that's actually in
in our ambition you will have seen that
in the report that we submitted so it's
very much part of our first ambition and
the work stream that is Led uh by one of
our officers and one of Trafford parent
carer Forum it's something we know we
have to do better and currently we
um certainly seek uh views through
various uh send conferences that were
organized through through ghost Hill and
the cabinet the youth cabinet also
provides opportunities for us to to
gather
um the voice of the child we also are
really committed to person-centered
reviews so anyhc plans are reviewed and
senkos have had training on how to
absolutely make sure that the the voice
of the child is shared through the
review but we are very clear that you
know we do not do this as well as we
should we're really committed to getting
that better and we know our schools and
families Champion their children really
really well particularly those who are
non-verb herbal and who may have
challenges in in communication so it's
something that we are committed to to
Really strengthening and improving
through ambition one if I can just start
as well one of the things that we do
have is a section on every ehcp plan
that is my plan that is about the child
The Young Person's own voice and our
senkos our schools work very creatively
with our our children and young people
to capture views so using pictures using
different AIDs that help with with
children and young people that are
non-verbal what we're less good at is
capturing the evidence of of those
pictures of those different mechanisms
and we need to be more systematic in
terms of doing that but there are some
really lovely examples of of how that is
shown on individual plans
yeah thank you sorry that just adds well
um we did have a focus on we have a
really well attended Senco Forum where
we share good practice and and we had a
focus on child voice at that just in um
uh recently in June
um and we were sharing some of those
methods so with mainstream staff who
perhaps aren't using some of those
methods and talking mats for example was
something that a colleague demonstrated
at that Forum so we're just trying to
share that good practice particularly
with those pre-verbal children okay and
we have sign along as well which is a
you know really helpful way of you know
people children being able to give their
voice okay Karina you missed the intros
at the beginning so could you just tell
us what your job role is sorry I'm Sally
Smith yeah I'm um the lead for some
special needs and inclusion nice to meet
you
thank you
um so the next question is why are the
numbers of refusals to assess higher
this year the test for requesting an
ehcp needs assessment is that the child
or young person may have special needs
it's a very low bar yeah we sought
clarification on which part of the
report uh this question had come from
um and the table if you if you look at
it says end of June so actually it's not
a full year so we don't have a complete
data set so you know some of those
percentages will be masked because we're
only part year so they are likely to
change okay
[Music]
um
so question 13
um the ehcp caseload has dropped in 2023
compared to
2022. why is this please and it's the
same point that actually it's part of
you so it will change
okay
and the final question we're doing well
with these um what is the current
situation with annual reviews are
changes families need being Incorporated
in the plans in a timely manner rather
than just the transition stages yeah and
again we'll provide a more for some uh
response to that it might be a report
that we could bring back scrutiny okay
thanks Karen appreciate that
um so obviously as members can see oh
sorry Dave did you yeah I just
is it one person who's asked all those
questions it's two people yeah two
different people
but not we don't normally have questions
do we but yeah
well answered as per usual thank you
with the
um
committee's permission we've got Sally
here who um has helped us with to put
together this Cam's task and finish
report so
um would the committee be okay with us
hearing this first and then
um Sally can get off home is that all
right so I'm going to introduce you have
had a copy of the report
um
we decided to work
with the health scrutiny group
um last year it's something I've wanted
to do for a long time it concerns me the
number of our young people who are
suffering mental health issues
um obviously there was a huge increase
in numbers during and post-covered it's
affected all our children from very
young up to teenage and University
students so their lives have changed I
think they're normal
um is something that's rather the fuzzy
area now
um
so I'd like to present the um report to
the committee with the recommendations
that we've made
um
and hopefully if you can agree we can
send this forward to the executive for
approval to get these recommendations
implemented Sally I don't know if you
wanted to say anything or if the
committee have got any questions
nope nope okay so with your permission
am I okay to forward this to the um
executive for their perusal thank you
very much
I'd just like to thank the councilors
actually which had helped um so
particular thanks go to
um Michael whetton who Vice chairs this
um with me and put a lot of time and
effort into it to
um
to think of the second names
to councilor Maitland who is no longer
in this committee who input a lot
um to councilor Hartley councilor Jorge
and I hope I've not missed anything
because I will be in trouble if I have
and I think that was everybody so with
thanks to those we did spend a lot of
time and thanks to the providers of the
services that um did take their time to
come and visit us and give us a lot of
information so thank you
um I'm going to move on from there to
item eight which is the children's
social care update and is that going to
be you Jill
or Pamela
um just by way of introduction
um obviously scrutiny have consistently
received reports on the Improvement
Journey for children's social care
colleagues and counselors will be very
much aware that actually at the end of
last year
um children's social care came out of
formal interventions and had our
Improvement notice lifted
and so we very much wanted to provide an
update to scrutiny in terms of our ongo
ongoing Improvement journey and at that
point I'm going to hand over to Pamela
who will talk you through the report
that's been provided this evening
sorry which item number sorry and I
think I I do apologize
item seven should have actually sent
updates sorry sorry so I don't know
which
um or do you want to take those in if
you want to do the send one first and
then the children's social care
anybody got any particular preference
[Music]
so sorry could you know which one was
being referred to the executive without
any questions so this was the um the
task and finish
um item nine
she wants to carry on yep okay thank you
thank you Jill
um we we've tattled this um report
continuous Improvement because we very
much see the the point that we are now
at in terms of being out of intervention
um and no longer inadequate as as Jill
referred to which was presented in the
February I think scrutiny a presentation
of of the outcome from the ilac as not
been the end point and I know that
members were were very assured by that
in in February we we acknowledge that we
still have a way to go in in children's
early help and social care to get to a
point where we are confident that our
services are consistently good for
children and families and so this report
what I hope it does for you is is to set
out the progress and our approach to
that Improvement and we have used used a
model
um which has been the isos research in
enabling Improvement in children's
services but we've very much based that
I'm doing the right thing for for our
children in Trafford but the Asos
research is a really helpful framework
um in terms of the the seven different
areas that that we focus on in order to
to improve services and we're hoping you
know to to continue that journey to
consistently good services
following the offset Alec inspection and
members that were here may remember
there were six areas for improvement the
offset set out and we needed to provide
um a response to those six areas for
ofsted which I have attached as a
document on the report and but what we
have done is we've built all of those
six areas into our existing Ambitions
plan so further in the report you see
the detail of the eight ambition areas
and those each of those areas has
remained the same so the the Strategic
areas that we're mindful of improving in
has remained the same but the activity
and the actions we are continually
updating and so we've we've woven the
six areas that ofsted highlighted which
which were areas that we were already
aware of
um into that plan
and just to assure people that there are
plans that's it beneath plans as well so
each of those six areas will have a plan
underneath them with a lot of of
detailing in those plans
so just in terms of of our way forward
in terms of and that continuous
Improvement as we've moved from a DFE
facilitated Improvement notice an
improvement board and we we had now
established through consultation with
board members and partner agencies and
Ambitions for children board that board
has has had its first um meeting with
the the new terms of reference really
pleased to say that the leader of the
council is is chairing that that board
for us which I think signifies the
importance of continuing that
Improvement Journey for children
we give consideration to a number of
factors in the establishing of that
board
um and we haven't had an operational
Steering group that sits beneath that
board and work streams for each of the
eight areas which in the um helpful
appendix I think at the bottom of the
report shows how that fits together
so we we have um an ambitious Ambitions
for children plan
um to get us to a point where in each of
those eight areas we we are confident uh
consistent we're we're reducing
variability and improving the quality of
practice so I realized that that is
quite a large document for people to
read so I just in the report pulled out
some of the key areas that we are taking
forward in this next phase of our
Improvement Journey against each of the
the ambition areas I think it's
important to say as well that that a
couple of the Ambitions and
dovetail and operate as the Strategic
safeguarding Partnerships
um
subgroups as well so to avoid that
duplication so for instance in neglect
and which is a significant uh
safeguarding issue for us in Trafford we
we have a joint Ambitions subgroup and
tssp because it's the same people around
the table that are driving that
improvement from across the partnership
so we're just being mindful of judicious
use of resources there as well
so a number of recommendations there for
for members of the committee to know the
formal reconfiguration the Ambitions for
children board
to continue to drive that quality to
note the detail of the Improvement
activity in the Ambitions for children
plan and noting that enhanced role of
some of those Ambitions leads and
jointly with with tssp and to receive on
an ongoing basis I would imagine and
updates with regards to progress against
key areas and activity and to provide as
you always have that really helpful
constructive Challenge and to ensure
that we are continuing to make a
difference for the children and young
people of Trafford
thanks Pamela does anybody have any
questions at all
Joe
so if I can just come in that's in
relation to the send report and the ehcp
timeliness
um so I don't know councilor Bennett if
you want to hang fire with that question
for when we talk about the send reports
the the report that Pamela was talking
about was the children's social care
report
I don't know if that's helpful or not
um
[Music]
so for children's social care and
assessments the time scales are very
different so we have to make a decision
within 24 hours about whether it's going
onward to be a referral we have to
complete assessments within 45 working
days for children's social care so at
that initial point of contact when
um a professional or a family gets in
touch about Children's
Welfare issues for want of a better
phrase and the service makes immediate
contact with that family and we're
required to look at how we work together
on a social care basis Karen I don't
know if you want to come in on there
yeah I mean certainly
um we can cover this off when I do the
the send report but in terms of the 20
weeks that's the statutory time scale in
terms of our issuing of EHC plans but we
can pick that up later on once I'll do
the send report if that will be helpful
in fact if I can just come in I think I
think you make a really good point in
terms of timeliness of intervention and
the right support at the right time for
families and in our ambition to write
help at the right time where we are
talking about the rollout of the
Trafford team together approach which is
supporting schools to to support
children and families and also our
family Hub and kind of repurposing our
current early help hubs into a family
help offer and I think it's really
important to families from what they
tell us to have accessible support in
their communities in in a um in a timely
way so I think it's a it's a point
really well made around the timeliness
of intervention when families start to
struggle rather than waiting until
things get in into a really difficult
situation
um
councilor Parker yeah it relates to
[Music]
so there's a dedicated domestic abuse
board that responds to the changes in
legislation and we were required to set
that up they have responsibility in
terms of some of the commissioning of
resources and sits under the auspices of
our community safety partnership so it I
guess the the governance Arrangements
reflect the complexity of domestic abuse
and and the continual interfaces
um there is a costed plan there are
commissioning resources
um that have been put into place one of
which is that in Trafford we have taken
on the lead and opened a male domestic
abuse refuge and that has been fully
costed there are commissioning of
services dedicated for children which
come from a variety of budgets including
the social care budget including the
early help commissioning resources and
the public health
budget if you ask me whether it was
sufficient and whether there was more we
would like to do so for example having
sustainable funding for a perpetrator
program then yes there is always more
that we would want and and seek to gain
that
um funding for so
um complex but yes there is funding in
place yes there are preventative
Services but it's the more that we could
utilize yes properly
does anybody else have any questions
counselor Hearst
yes I wanted to ask
oh sorry Council animal counselors okay
just know when you're using the mic you
just have to press it once to turn on
because people are turning on and then
turn it off again so I just want to know
thank you
um
counselor and be the participation and
engagement service we've recently taken
um a decision to move that service into
the youth engagement service
um so the we have a very small
participation and engagement service
which has
um as you know you'll you'll probably as
a as a foster carer have met with a
number of members of of those team and
we've had some changes in in the
Personnel in that team
um but we are moving that into the wider
youth engagement service to make better
use of that holistic resource really so
and Andy Zilker who leads the youth
engagement service will be leading
um on that work and I think what we what
we understand and know from from the the
various groups of care for children and
care experience on people it's a it's
quite a small group of young people who
regularly attend who come to corporate
parenting board and and present the
views of of cared for children and
people so our ambition is is to grow the
number of children and people who feel
able to participate so that the voice
um on in terms of that decision making
any and influencing
um the way that we develop our services
is is on a wider footprint of children
from young people and of course we're
partnering with our with our carers and
who are looking after those children
without Foster carers or residential
workers to support and enable more
children and young people to become
um involved and to have a voice and we
we want to ensure that in individual
children and people's circumstances in
cared for children reviews and Care
planning meetings that their voice is
Central
whether they are physically there or
whether their views are represented in
other in other mechanisms and we've more
to do to improve that to make those
meetings the child Young Person's
meeting that they can share those
meetings that they decide who's invited
to those meet meetings so it's on a very
individual childbir child which I ended
up the circus back is because it's
children and young people that they are
their voice in terms of decisions about
them and plans for them
um on a day-to-day basis or outworked
but also then in terms of the the
development of services and and how we
move care planning and quality of
practice forward that those young people
um are are given that voice and that
co-creation with us and I know that um
councilor Carter our new lead member is
a very keen to um
think how about how we do that
differently within the corporate
parenting board as well
if I can just come in one of the
examples of a piece of work that well
there's a number of pieces of work that
are ongoing at the moment one of those
examples was actually taking the
Ambitions plan to meet with a group of
children and young people but not just
from the um children in Care Council or
the Aftercare Forum but engaging with
young people from our our schools
councils to say these are the things
that we think are really important these
are the things that our partners think
are really important what do you think
and and they gave some absolutely as you
would expect some stunning feedback
um one of which which absolutely
um blew me away with say actually if
you're serious about early intervention
you need to talk to us first before you
talk to the grown-ups
um which you know never a truer word was
that some real insight about
um trust and confidence in professionals
not just social Care Professionals
social workers but do you really think
teachers are the best place for people
to identify if I'm living in neglectful
circumstances
um what does it mean if I don't picture
up at school regularly what does that
mean
um so we've given a commitment to go
back and meet with that broader group of
young people with what we've done and
how we've acted upon their feedback and
some big strategic pieces of work
following the motion that was passed
earlier on
um in terms of care leavers as a
protector characteristic so the Pew Andy
Zilker in terms of that youth engagement
service taking on the participation bit
is what does that actually mean what
what do you see
that we as the adults as the partnership
as the businesses need to do to enact
that motion rather than it just being a
tick in the box which I know
um none of our elected members would
want to to see it's got to be meaningful
which is one of the reasons why it felt
right to talk to all young people about
what you think about this because some
people won't want to self-identify as
having been care experience for others
it's really really important so how we
act that out and take that forward is
another piece of key work that we're
taking forward
thanks Jill councilor deacon
okay thanks Council Proctor
of course
sorry um just to say as well across
greater Manchester with the ICB now
forming
um we've commissioned a provider youth
Focus Northwest to establish two groups
that one is going to focus on supporting
some of our health services from an
operational point of view in terms of
how they should be delivering and
conducting some reviews and also the
second group will be carrying out some
more strategic work so feeding in into
GM strategies great amount of strategies
sorry around some of our health services
so over the next 12 months I've
identified two services that they want
well two areas they want to look at and
one is cams as in uh core Cam's offer
and so they will be scrutinized by this
group
um over the next 12 months in terms of
delivery and also the Strategic group
are going to look into children
presenting in crisis to hospitals so
just to say there's that other piece of
work going on as well
foreign
I'm not sure where to ask this question
so I'm going for here
and because it's it
it's going to be covered later as well
you'll recall
maybe two years ago I asked about ehcps
and why are we reassessing children
you're on you're on your where their
needs
don't change because the conditions they
have aren't suddenly going to recover
later because we're statutorily required
to carry out an annual review and you're
right that some needs won't change but
some might actually get and need might
increase if we've got the plan right the
the need in terms of the Education
Health and Care elements might look
slightly different so how we do the
review and the best mechanism for doing
that so as it fully looks at Education
Health and Care is part of the um send
ambition work that we're taking forward
I think just just to come back on that
we're not reassessing we're reviewing
the HC plan and I think that's you know
that there is a slight difference
because it is making sure that the plan
is relevant and meaningful and he's
going to support the young person that's
the important thing because as we all
know historically that hasn't been the
case and it's been a complete
reassessment and
um
people children have had their support
packages removed and have had to fight
to get them back so that's really good
that is simply a review rather than
starting from scratch so sorry I now
can't see you but I couldn't read
ambition two and three
how are we going to make that happen so
that children and families receive
the very specific help they need when
they need it as opposed to
suiting our the service we offer and how
are we going to make sure that a child
in the North or the west or the South
will receive the same quality of service
thank you
I'll start with that one and I'm sure my
colleagues um will come in so
um in terms of the right help at the
right time that that family help offer
and that core production with our
communities is is really important and
we we have been having a number of
events
um with um The Innovation unit initially
were helping us with with some of that
work to give that Independence and some
of that oversight
um we have now appointed a head of
service for family help who is driving
forward this work and um we are piloting
an approach in the north of the borough
I think what what's come across from the
work that we've done
um across Trafford is that you're
absolutely right families having a
consistent
um Services is really important but the
needs are different in the different
localities
the makeup of communities is different
and so very much a one-size-fits all
from early years up to poor 16 is
probably not going to work so we all and
we have different Community groups as
and Faith groups in in each of the the
localities of the borough as well so
it's really important that we've taken
that time to undertake that needs
analysis of the localities and and work
with our families with the third sector
who are doing some fabulous work all
across Trafford so that we don't
duplicate work but we met best use of
that that Collective resource that we
have and really positive that the
community Collective have secured some
additional funding that will I think
enhance the neighborhood model and the
family help offer
um within that yeah I'll just just come
in on that um I think your abs you raise
a really really good point because
um obviously the needs assessment and
the data is informed where we pilot
things in the first instance so it was
really important for us to go to the
north and go to Partington particularly
to to really make sure the offer for our
communities is is really what what is
needed but schools frequently tell me
what about us in the South What About Us
in central
um absolutely so we are acutely aware of
the need to make sure we get this
certainly the offer and and starting
with Trafford team together across the
borough in a timely way so we've got a
clear recruitment
um drive going on we're really committed
to making sure that that offer is there
and as as Pamela said you know as we
roll out family hubs Family Help
um we're really clear that that is about
creating an offer by it's being created
by the community for the community
because they know what what is needed in
their community so you're right we have
piloted um a start for Life project in
North you know really thinking about how
children will Thrive and develop and
flourish in the north getting the naught
to two off a right because I don't think
we've always got those Thousand and One
critical days where they need to be but
Zoe Sweeney our new head of service for
early years and family help is just it's
very tenacious and she's very passionate
about getting the right support for our
families when they need it
if I can just start within your pack of
papers you have got
um our early help needs analysis that's
being carried out across the partnership
that
um I we felt was a really really
important piece of work and an important
document because if we're serious about
race help right time we need to
understand what the need is what
um what's working well what
um is a challenge for some of our
children young people and our family so
as we can tailor the offer to support
that and I think it's fair to say that
over the last three years we have worked
to turn some of our responses on its
head that actually whatever the worry is
whatever the issue is it's a worry or an
issue and it's about finding the right
person to support at that time of need
and we all need some help at different
times
um and and rather than computer says no
or no it's not for us doesn't meet the
threshold you know it part of our
ambition is to not even have a threshold
document a level of needs document but
to make all of the conversations about
children and families we're not there
yet we have had the Trafford team
together model evaluated externally it
was a really really positive evaluation
does that mean that we haven't got more
to do no it doesn't
um but again that was a really important
thing to do to test the efficacy of the
model and to continue to work with our
partners to further strengthen because
actually the local Authority might not
always be the best place people to
respond you know sometimes people are
fearful of social care and we have to
recognize that but think what's our
unique contribution to that helping that
enabling
um so not a short Quick Fix but it one
of the things that we're really clear
about in terms of our ambition plan is
that it's not a static plan it's a
dynamic document that will change and
evolve over time and we've deliberately
called it an ambitious plan Ambitions
plan because it is ambitious you know
tackling neglect is a a long-term
commitment tackling domestic abuse is a
long-term commitment but that's why we
think they are the right things to be
focused on not because ofsted told us
because they're the things that have
combustible and from that real close
look at what we're doing well what we
need to strengthen and what will make
the greatest difference to our children
and families
that's great thank you um can I Council
on councilor Ennis and then councilor
please
thanks Jay um so I'm new to the
committee and there's definitely a lot
to learn so thanks to the report and and
the Insight I'm just wondering could you
tell us a bit more about how does the
relatively High turnover in the social
care sector impact our ability to plan
strategically like this and also if you
could expand a little bit more on the
role of the third sector and how that's
factored in uh at a strategic level
I've had the the workforce first is is
that okay and we we've had our DMT
development day today and one of one of
the core things that we've been talking
about is is stability
um because I think what we've what we
found with um a change in Workforce of
the the last kind of three years is that
you you're almost continually starting
again
um and that has hampered us at different
points and we've certainly
um invested I think in in the Ambitions
plan you'll see that um invested in our
people strategy around the workforce is
a key enabler to to all of this so we
know for children for instance and
foster carers and residential workers
the the continual changing of social
workers impacts their ability to build
relationships and build that trust and
confidence
um and it impacts Us in terms of being
able to drive forward and get on to the
next phase of the journey so that
Relentless focus on enabling Trafford
children's services and children's
social care in particularly to be
um
at a department where Social Work
practice flourishes people are attracted
to come but more importantly and they're
feeling able to stay by the the offer
here
um corporately and in the service so
we've we we're working very hard at
making sure that we are
um competitive attractive for people to
join us but look at looking after people
treating people well treating people
with kindness as we as we like to say
um so that people want want to stay for
children and and for for the service in
order so that that continuous
development the two sides of the same
coin we can't enable continuous
Improvement strategically if we don't
have a stable secure Workforce
we've done um one of the things that we
have done and that we continue to do is
to understand and analyze why people
stay with us why people might leave us
some of that is for positive reasons you
know and if we're genuinely a learning
organization that encourages people and
some people will even get promotion
elsewhere some people leave for very
personal reasons and we saw that acutely
during the the pandemic years really
um what we what we do know though is if
we create the conditions for social work
practice to succeed to flourish and to
the parts of the service if we look
after our people in the right way if we
have shared values shared Visions if we
give them the kit that they need to do
their job if we do connect in terms of
of
um make it and guess all about children
and families people come to work to do a
good job they don't come to work to do a
bad job people work in children's
services because they want to make a
difference so putting some of those
things all together like a little bit of
the jigsaw is absolutely a key enabler
um to building that stability that
consistency
having consistency of approach so it
doesn't matter whether somebody comes to
me they go to Pamela or they go to Karen
knowing that there's going to be the
same approach the same value placed on
that they're listened to all of those
things really help with that stability
having said that we do know that
nationally in public sector it's
probably the most challenging it's been
from a Workforce perspective whether
that's within the Health Service whether
that's within social care it is tough
which makes it even more important that
we look after our people and do the
right thing for them
okay move on to the third sector I think
that was the second point that you asked
about
um our our former DFE advisor um saw it
as a key strength and we have
representative from the third sector on
our Improvement board they will continue
to be a key partner in the Ambitions for
children's board in the governance
Arrangements of the startwell board we
have that
um connectivity there and in the the
subgroups that are they're underneath
the best Beginnings board the early help
board and also within within that send
um partnership world as well so we we
see them as as being integral
um because the majority of of Children
and Families are receiving Universal
Services and a lot of that is delivered
through fear sector third sector
organizations in Trafford and so it is
it is a key strength we're not um
resting on our Laurels with that we'll
continue to to push in with that and
seeing that as a as a key enabler as
well to to draft forward the on the
journey
so again going back to the needs
assessment that's within the park on the
back of that we have put a range of
services out to Tender and we've made
the specifications much more based on
this is the type of service these are
the needs that that we think exist and
being less less prescriptive but more
demanding in some ways to encourage and
enable our third sector Partners to
really think creatively about how they
would meet that need rather than saying
actually we need more peer mentoring
Services if this is the need for our
children and families how would you as a
as a vital part of our infrastructure
provide that service so again
recognizing the unique contributions of
our third sector partners and I think
it's Real Testament to the strength of
that in Trafford that the community
Collective and to support the social
Care Improvement Journey improved
outcomes for children and young people
they have a dedicated Children's Group
that meets about the Ambitions work that
that links back into us so that genuine
recognition about it's definitely a
collaborative effort it's definitely a
partnership I'm recognizing everybody's
unique contribution I think we are
starting to see some of the the benefits
from that way of working collaboratively
it's just a very quick one on the back
of what Jill said before you mentioned
how well Trafford team together is going
which is really great to hear and I know
it was rolled out in the north and in
the South and in the west and it was due
to be rolled out in the center
um in Spring 2023 are we there with
that progress
we're all going for a ride and um I
think it's Real Testament to the support
that the service have heard that we've
been in a position to invest in a
preventative approach so I took some
money out of Pamela's budget but don't
tell her
um because it absolutely is the right
thing to do
um and we are hoping in um the awesome
term to have
um an event that showcases the benefits
of the model and where we're going next
with it but yes it is on track to be
rolled out
because I just want to make sure
that we're not being overlooked and I
think the other piece of work that was
really interesting was the um work that
we did in terms of understanding the
work of our intensive family support
service and a lot of
um families and new people that were
being supported through that service
there were
um send needs and learning needs not
necessarily cognitive learning needs but
there were
additional needs that we needed to think
about so we very much see that as part
of the Continuum and Pamela touched on
our development time that we had today
and I think one of the things that we've
been really good at working at is
understanding and innovating even during
the pandemic so that's when Trafford
team together started family hubs Family
Help is is part of that as is intensive
Family Support so I
it's exciting times I think I think just
on the rollout of TTT it's important we
did the evaluation piece as well to
really make sure that the model was was
as successful as we wanted it to be and
I think with the new head of service
we've got a great opportunity to really
drive forward that rollout just the
referrals to it is not necessarily
coming through TTT the majority of our
referrals come from schools and
obviously we are seeing an increase in
from parents as well but Jill's right I
think what TTT are telling us is that a
loss of the children who are getting
support through TTT and their families
actually do have identified additional
needs
thank you councilor Acton
thank you chair
um I think it is a really good report
and it's easy to read and it's easy to
understand
um and I think
um the the Ambitions are excellent
um but how are we going to deliver
you know and I'll measure success in
terms of the outcomes on each of the
um the eight Ambitions that are there
and how how will we sort of monitor that
through the process because it's going
to take a while to to get where we want
I assume
thank you for your feedback that that's
really encouraging thank you and I
thought it might have been a stretch too
far for me to embed the performance
framework that sits alongside the
Ambitions plan but I'm happy to to share
that post meeting if that would be
helpful so against each of the eight
Ambitions we have a series of measures
both quantitative and qualitative in
terms of measuring that that success and
we have been working to set some stretch
targets to ensure that um we don't get
too comfortable that we we're ambitious
in that stretch and what we are looking
for in terms of those those Target
settings so for instance if I use
quality of practice as an example
um members will know we have a quality
assurance framework where managers look
in detail at Children's situations the
intervention that we've offered and give
give enough raw rating but there are
four sub-areas assessment planning
management oversight and outcomes for
children and we're looking to stretch
the the the the aspiration that the
majority of of our internal audits
um judge those services to be good for
children
um so we're we're not there and but we
are ambitious for 80 90 of of those
audits to be judging services to be to
be good
in terms of the accountability one of
the key
um
aspects of the terms of reference for
the Ambitions board is to hold the
service to accountant to monitor the
performance against that agreed
scorecard and as Pamela's already said
the leader of the council chairs that
um Ambitions board so I don't think
we've got any wriggle room on that one
really in terms of it but it's really
important that we we do have targets
it's really important that we have
measures of success and that those
measures include those qualitative
measures in terms of actually the
ultimate test is whether it has made a
difference to our children and families
and whether we know that will be based
on their feedback and whether they say
we have been helpful to them
um which is complicated to to get that
feedback and and will involve and does
involve a range of different ways but
it's really important that we do that
not just use the the national indicators
I think it would be useful periodically
to have a report on the progress that is
being made I'm sure you'll do that of
course
yeah absolutely maybe happy to come back
to us maybe once every six months or so
and let us know how it's all going but
thank you for the report thank you to
members for I thought you'd be shy some
of you knew but uh evidently not so it's
good to know we've got a lively bunch
um can we move on to the um send updates
if that's okay and I don't know who's
going to start with this one I think
what I'll do if it's okay chair I'll
just uh lift out a few of the highlights
the headlines if you like from the
report and then open up for questions
and I'm sure Sally uh will be able to to
respond to some of the questions as well
so
um it was quite a broad remix so I tried
to cover as much as we could within the
report but accepting
um that the scrutiny committee may
require some additional information at a
later date if they want more in-depth
information
um what I've tried to do is to share our
vision uh for send and share that we
have a genuine commitment to improving
the experience and outcomes for our
children and families because we know
the impact of covid has been and will
continue to be really quite profound
um for our children a lot has happened
um particularly in the last couple of
years and post covered but we are also
clear that more needs to be done to make
things better and to make the experience
for our children and families
um much better much stronger we we do
have a long way to go but we don't shy
away from that and we're really
committed to making sure that we do
everything we can and through listening
to to the lived experience of our
children and families you'll see that
we've renewed our governance
Arrangements
um and that has been really important to
us in terms of responding to changing
and emerging needs particularly
post-pandemic but also some of those
system-wide pressures and that's whether
it's in the education sector as we know
our schools are really struggling
financially now and they're also
struggling to recruit to support some of
our most vulnerable children and young
people and also the pressures in the
health health service we know our
waiting times for our families are you
know are really quite long and and
there's real significant demand
pressures in in the health system
um so we've had to do that and and
particularly in in kind of that backdrop
of the realignment of of the ccg and the
local Authority as well and and we've
we've tried to to share with you
um some of the the new governance
Arrangements you'll see that we have um
recruited if you like an independent
chair for our son's strategic board and
this is somebody Edwina Grant who is
incredibly
um challenging uh incredibly rigorous
but very knowledgeable and she has a an
awful lot of knowledge and experience of
send herself
um but also she's she's
um very in touch with some of the
um government strategies the government
pieces of work she's worked with local
authorities who have got significant
deficit budgets and for high needs Etc
so she's bringing a wealth of experience
and we thought that independent eye
would be really helpful to us as well
but her brief is also about creating the
conditions of success so we get to a
point where the chair of the board can
actually be our families too and parents
so a co-chairing Arrangement including
Health Partners and um parent carers so
we're really committed to to making that
happen
um I think something else that we've
picked we've we've cited in the report
and it kind of links in with what Pamela
has been sharing about making sure we've
got the right help at the right time and
that's making sure that we've got a
clear graduated approach so that
actually children and young people can
get a really strong offer in without the
need for an EHC plan so actually
um that ordinarily available provision
should be inclusive and should be able
to meet children's needs and that
applies to all of our schools and early
year settings as well so really
committed to that obviously the family
help strategy which we've talked about
but also the inclusion Charter as well
that we've rolled out across our schools
which is a series of principles really
that we want our schools to sign up to a
real commitment to show that they will
be truly inclusive and within a high
States accountability system that
education is that can be quite a
balancing act but we're really Keen to
make sure that we progress that with our
schools
we share our Ambitions plan those are
just the the main Ambitions obviously
there's plans that sit underneath it in
terms of the detail work streams that
will endeavor to deliver on those
Ambitions and also key metrics where we
can
um really
um test ourselves and hold ourselves to
account and measure performance
the Ambitions plan was actually
co-produced with families and so it was
done on the back of a workshop we held
in conjunction with families and with
Trafford parent carer forum and we've
actually asked Trafford parent carer
Forum to look at all the Ambitions and
give us a send check as to whether those
feel right for families and whether
they're clear and they're understood
they also identify the outcomes for
children in the council for disabled
children did a workshop with us a couple
of years ago now where we identified as
a system including families and what
outcomes for children were you know what
what they needed to be in Trafford so
they also informed some of the ambitions
you'll see the data around the growth in
plans
um so again we're not unlike many local
authorities and not unlike the national
position as you can see and it's
understandable and again in the context
of covid and I think what is really
interesting for me at the moment is the
rise in very young children now where
we're seeing requests for needs
assessments and referrals in in into
plans and really needing that additional
support particularly in speech language
and communication for our very young
children but also social emotional and
mental health needs again still in our
young children that emotional regulation
as well in as in the older children and
young people
shared some context around the send
rates in the borough and and tried to
show that in terms of Ward data and some
of the Year group and also so a little
bit of context really about where the
sun needs are and just a little
um sort of reminder about that data that
is data that we've pulled from Trafford
schools so it won't automatically
collect information from Outer Borough
placements or also some of our
independent non-maintained sector as
well specialist sectors so it's it tends
to be the more local local position but
you can see where there's areas of
deprivation that's where we're seeing
some of the highest and need
and you see in the year group you see
that spike in when children are just um
getting closer to transition into
secondary and we know in Trafford we've
got a very interesting secondary picture
selective but also our faith schools our
real good all girls all boys schools
it's a very very complex uh position in
Trafford so you can see there's a real
anxiety I think as children approach
transition also the year 12 where you
see a drop-off from from year 11 and
that that actually again because it
doesn't reflect the Outer Borough and
the um Fe placements there is a little
bit of a caveat around that it just
reflects the post 16 provision that we
have actually in traffic but Sally can
probably articulate that later on and if
if that's needed just provide some
clarification around that we've talked
about the 20-week time scale that is the
statutory time scale by which we have to
issue a plan and and I've tried to sort
of identify the Milestones as we work
through that 20 weeks and we know a lot
of our families are frustrated when we
don't do that in a timely way when we
don't issue the plan and we send Draft
plans we absolutely want to make sure
that parents co-produce those plans and
help us to write those plans and young
people as well so that their voice and
and experiences the golden thread
throughout we also have to seek advice
from social care and Health Partners
which takes a bit of time and so
sometimes there are frustrations we we
understand that but we're really
committed to making sure we try to do it
in a timely way hence there is no 21st
week is is is our Mantra that's what
we're really working hard towards
sometimes though it's the right thing to
give the plan a bit of extra time
because sometimes it's important we get
the plan right and we get a quality plan
so equally we don't want to rush it
through either so it can be a bit of a
complex balance there and we've got
plans in place just to make sure that we
we improve move on that and the quality
of plans is a real Focus for us at the
moment because as I said you can issue a
plan but actually it it may not be a
very effective high quality plan so
we're working really hard in getting the
quality assurance mechanisms around the
plans as robust as as possible so we've
recently established a a more robust
framework which includes stronger
auditing process and multi-agency
auditing as well because send is
education it's health and its social
care it's a system rather than a local
Authority and I think that's really
important so you know trying to get
really strong advice and high quality
support and input from all of the
providers across the system is is really
important but I've also referred to some
of the other quality assurance
mechanisms we've had like the leap
panels the lived experience panels those
have been absolutely tremendous to us it
was actually came from Trafford parent
carer Forum they initiated they created
this and it's been such a powerful
opportunity for us to really hear the
lived experience of families it's been
hard it's been hard listening
um it's
you know it's been very humbling
um and and we've had a real sense check
of how it feels but actually it's been
really helpful in this us making sure we
transform our service delivery and
actually we listen but we actively
listen and we do something about it so
you know that that has been a real
powerful and important piece of work
um and I think that that's probably it
so hopefully you know it's been it's you
know it's given you as much information
as as we could but happy to accept
questions and provide further
information at a lay State thank you
Karen um I'm just delighted to see that
we did some task and finish work on this
four or five years ago on ehcps and some
of our recommendations have been put in
place so I think that just demonstrates
how these guys listen
um you know to advise on how important
scrutiny of any element of the services
so does anybody have any questions on
the report
counselor Sutton first
yeah
thanks
um uh yes like counselor NSL earlier on
uh news new to this committee uh so yes
the Steep learning curve but thank you
for this report
um there's a I've got a few few uh
various uh questions first
um first thing I wanted to uh note
looking at the requests for the actually
Plans by year and the plans issued uh I
don't think anybody's under any uh
surprises that there was a peaking
request in 2022 and both posts covered
post pandemic
um but what jumps out admits to me there
is the the proportion of plans issued in
2022 was uh a a far greater percentage
of requests than it was in 2021 and it
looks like 2023 so that's 2021 I just
wanted to know if there's any
understanding of why the proportion of
plans issued in 2022 was that much
higher
so um the data in terms of the number
the percentage of plans issued in 2021
um and it dropped to 40 in 22 and by the
end of June currently we're around 59 so
um 40 is absolutely not what it should
be at all that is really low uh and we
were very disappointed
um in that percentage of issuing
um that is within the time scale within
the 20s sorry sorry there's a
misunderstanding well then I wasn't
looking at that percentage I meant if
you look at the first two first two rows
the 2022 455 issued out of 518.
is top of my head
80 or 90 of requests ended up with a
plan being issued which is very
different from the previous subsequent
yeah I think there's also a knock-on
effect though there so sometimes with
the timeliness some of those won't be an
issued in that calendar year but it will
have been issued later so it does it's
not a direct proportion of the numbers
of requests received within the calendar
and the numbers issued within that
calendar year does that make sense yeah
I would appreciate it
was just something that jumped out out
to me when I was looking at the figures
uh um
uh as some already mentioned about
looking at the um uh uh the the the the
ehtps in different year groups uh and uh
under what the report manager describes
it as a spike from year four tier five
um looking at where I draw a trend line
on that chart I describe it more as a
deflation in years three and year four
uh and I'm wondering what
um situation there is
um either schools less reluctance to uh
in mainstream schools less reluctant to
seek uh uh uh go down the hcp routes in
uh in the earlier years
um for whatever reason uh but also as
well as that transition to year seven
um if there's an issue with limited
schools resources being focused on
getting ehcps in place before SATs and
year six
I think
um when you talk about deflation I think
there is another Peak there at year two
personally you know so I think there's
the they're in key stages really I would
say that the key stage probably schools
put that focus on referring by the end
of key stage one and then consider it
again ready for the end of key stage two
when they're seeing those big
Transitions and changes
um does that answer the first bit I
don't you know when it drops off at year
three I think it's more of a Peak at
year two personally than a and that just
doesn't quite go as an a gradual
increase
I think preparing for transition does
cause a lot of concern and we're doing a
lot to try and build parental confidence
particularly as well as school
confidence in the secondary sector but
our Primary in secondary senkos together
at The Forum looking at that what does
provision look like in the secondary
sector that is going to be able to meet
needs because I think even from some of
the senko sometimes they think oh will
they will they cope but then we need to
make sure that they're confident in what
the child's going to at secondary
um so but there are still a lot of
referrals at that point and sometimes
you know plans are issued at that for
that transition and because it does you
know provision does look different at
secondary so and so what you were I I
don't think it's anything to do with
SATs necessarily
um I mean an EHC plan will enable a
child to have some additional time
um for SATs
um but you know they they would still
sit sit the test anyway and actually the
results for SATs
um hasn't hasn't been published recently
won't necessarily indicate where a child
goes to either into in terms of their
secondary reprovision I think it is more
recognizing that the secondary school is
a very very different environment
um and you know children will be going
to various classes various teachers
um it you know it is very very different
and not always with their friends so I
think it's more around just getting that
provision that support in place
um to to enable them to seamlessly move
into the secondary sector and be
supported during those early years seven
and eight years particularly
um thanks uh um just going back to the
the key stage one key stage two
situation
um I
I know if so somebody's able to explain
to me why it needs that it needs to
start again at the beginning of of year
three because although the curriculum
changes uh the the the the the
additional needs uh don't reset again so
it it still looks to me on that graph
that there's something going wrong with
under diagnosis around that year three
year four level I think it will be
interesting this is a snapshot in time
so I think it will be interesting to
look at Trends over the years this is
the current position in Trafford
um so I think it would be interesting to
see what that looks like over time and
whether there is something in terms of
either not identifying needs or actually
the children have already had them
identified in year two so actually you
know there's less children coming
through the system necessarily into year
three and four
yes so the the snap showing time in
particularly in relation to covid has
something can bring up in a later point
on the agenda
um a couple just a couple more questions
one about the Justice on the same page
the sem rates by gender
um
could I suggest that would be better
titled as scn diagnosis rights by gender
I think actually it's um it's send rate
so that's not just children within EHC
plan so that's children who have been
supported at send support as well
um so that's
um that's the data we we can actually
um we can look at that data in relation
to primary need
um but we'd have to do you know quite a
significant breakdown so we can see
again if there are any trends of males
and females against specific needs and
so we can certainly look at that if that
will be helpful
um that would that would be it'll be
um particularly interesting I've been
interested to see it with a breakdown
with those related to the
neurodivergence in particular uh because
I think it's a wide widespread
understanding that there is an issue of
of gender bias and diagnosis I think
what we are finding as well that perhaps
if I'm right Sally there's a a you know
a higher proportion of girls with ASC or
or who are neurodivergent who may mask
yeah so we we're certainly aware of that
can I just say
um just on the diagnosis though because
within special needs we do very much
talk about the presenting need and not
diagnosis so because somebody with you
know there may be somebody with autism
who coached really well without needing
to be on scn somebody else might be scn
support somebody else will need the
support of a plan so we don't we really
try to avoid linking the two in the
sense of diagnosis so I always talk
about identification of need rather than
that book yeah I mean there's a lot
there's a lot of work at poor poor
choice of that would be identified SEO
or something
but there is a lot of work going on as
well around
um you know with our autism and schools
projects and and other training around
girls with autism particularly to
improve that diagnose sorry
identification I'm doing it now prove
that identification within schools yeah
thanks
um fine uh final question I was pleased
to reference earlier about
um the pupils voice in annual reviews
and so on uh about making efforts to
include alternative ways of reporting
people's uh Charlie and personal's Views
um to two parts of that the the
description area mainly referred to
dealing with uh non-verbal children but
is there encouragement to use those kind
of alternative methods more widely
wherever uh wherever appropriate an
individual uh and also are there if you
looked at ways of including audio and
video evidence as part of that as well
as other physical photographic evidence
so
uh yeah very much so that was part of
the conversation really and the the
suggestion of things like the talking
mats isn't necessarily that somebody
couldn't speak it's about you know the
timing of getting their review their
voice and we were also looking at you
know what's the purpose of getting the
voice whether it was for a new referral
um or whether it's an annual review we
need to improve and get the senko's
thinking particularly when they're
Gathering it or is it a parent who's
gathered it making sure we know how it's
been gathered and but some of the tools
um as you mentioned in something around
our we've got a toolkit for emotionally
based school non-attendance at the
moment and that's um one of the key
strategies there is to use cards you
know that the young people can use to be
able to say this is this looks like me
this is how I feel and this doesn't seem
like me
um as a sorting activity as a way in so
it doesn't rely on them using their
voice because we know a lot of young
people especially near our Divergent
don't want to uh share you know we could
ask them if they're all right and
they'll say yes doesn't mean they're
right
um so it is it's yeah we're trying to
expand that knowledge and I know a
couple of the special schools who've had
it as a focus in their development plans
as well around
um the kind of more pre-verbal and
making sure they're getting the voice
but um yeah we're trying to expand that
that way of working to make sure it's
used across mainstream
that's great thanks thank you councilor
deakin did you have a question yeah yeah
thank you um thank you again for the
report it's really helpful
um just in terms of the uh I wanted to
ask on the status of the communication
strategy uh and whether that have yet
been implemented and
what that kind of looks like in terms of
um setting out really clearly what
people can expect when they do get in
touch you know I appreciate how busy you
guys must be with those figures
um but I think you know a lot of
people's concerns come from some
certainty of when when it might be
coming so it just help us understand
that and then also will that be shared
as you know I think it's a useful thing
for counselors to understand when we get
casework around you this is something
we've identified and put into the
Ambitions plan we're at the early stages
with it we've got a new EHC team manager
starting tomorrow thank goodness
um the slight Gap in in uh since the
previous member left so
um but it's that we've at the moment
we've
um identified two other models that we
really like in two different authorities
so I'm just waiting for him to start
tomorrow and that's on our agenda to
take forward with the team because it's
mainly about
um DHC team themselves and how they
communicate with schools how they
communicate with parents but very much
so
um in the plan would be to work with
parent Forum traffic forum and sending
us on that as well and then it would be
published on our local offer we do have
a communication and engagement group as
well yeah
um and that has a range of of partners
that that
um attend the communication engagement
group they're kind of leading ambition
one as well around the voice of the
young person so that is absolutely about
uh finding out from the likes of sandias
which is the independent advisory
support service you know what calls are
coming through to them what families are
telling us how we need to communicate
better Trafford parent care reform
attend that as as well as other
providers so that is a really useful
mechanism to make sure that that
communication strategy is right but
you're right Sally the local offer is
absolutely the place that we need to
ensure is is user friendly because you
know that that's the place which will
hold all of our send information and
it's known and understood and valued by
our parents and young people
so just to add one of the things that's
going to be happening over the the
summer is a development day with the
ehcp team so as Sally said having
researched models of best practice from
from elsewhere thinking about the way
that our current service and team is
organized and that point of contact and
what that means for the resource base
within that team because if they're
saying actually as soon as a request is
made there's going to be a personal
contact from a named person that
inevitably will have implications in
terms of the resource base and what we
look at so there's something about
thinking about what our our aim is for
that service how it can genuinely be as
responsive as possible and how that
links with the the policy Direction
um because National policy is very much
more thinking about how we can provide
help and support rather than thinking
about ehcp as a process and a diagnosis
a medical model so there's there's a bit
to unpack and unpick in terms of moving
away from being process driven to being
relational based and what that does mean
um so the there are some real strengths
so for example when
decisions are made not to assess or when
it's not to issue a palm a plan there is
a personal contact from the leaders of
the service if we want to extend that
approach much earlier we do need to
think about what the the resourcing and
the model looks like
come on that meeting with families when
we don't agree to assess and we don't
agree to issue I think I mean Sally will
want to expand on it because Sally's the
one that leads those meetings but it's
it's really helpful in giving parents
the rationale for the decision because
we accept that very often there will be
a feeling that decisions are made behind
closed doors and and you know what does
that mean for me so sorry I don't know
yeah just to um we've had it in place
for a couple of years now but um it it
we really felt that and we say in the
letters try to make our any no letters
kind of as bespoke as we can with an
explanation but we offer them eating and
we're proactive about arranging the
meeting rather than waiting for somebody
to ask for it as well
um so that's always been with a member
of panel either the HC manager myself or
one of the other panel members um that
have been part of that decision and
heard it made
um go along and we always say we've come
with an open mind it doesn't affect any
other rights to appeal in more formal
ways but we go to explain what the
conversation was make sure they've
understood the letter
um but also if there's any new
information so you know we've missed
something then people can discuss that I
always ask about
how is the child today you know so since
we discussed it a panel there may have
been changes
um and we invite the school so it's
always with the the setting and the
parent generally if it's a no to issue
we've already carried out an assessment
then we'll also involve any of the other
professionals we can so maybe the
educational psychologist might join us
but those have been really helpful you
know sometimes we've taken we have
overturned a decision we've taken it
back to panel and said actually we've
not quite got this right let's not carry
on any further down formal routes of
appeal let's go back
um but generally quite a lot of those
around that year six seven transition as
well and and they have been around lack
of confidence and those have been able
easy to kind of then resolve and we
sometimes agree follow-up meetings
involving the secondary school ready so
they can hear and once they've got that
confidence then we can hand it back over
to the schools and but they've yeah
they've been really successful
[Music]
Parker did you have a question
I think
um thank you so much for this report I
really like data so it was really
helpful
um from the data though provided in it
it looks like and this might be my
reading of it that boys would send from
low-income households on free School
meals could be those who are most likely
going to be impacted by the delays in
issuing EHC plans so I just wanted to
check what strategic plans and
initiatives are in place to Target that
demographic
um I think that's a really interesting
observation
um I think we're working hard at
um
sort of that early identification
actually
um one of our Ambitions is linked to
best start for life and we know that you
know our best Beginnings board where
we're really thinking about our very
young children that our boys do not
necessarily perform as well as our girls
or don't have the same outcomes we know
that very often they may not attend
Early Education that it's not always a
priority for them they just want to play
and and who can blame them really
um so but what you know that is
something that we are acutely aware of
and really working hard with the early
years sector as well to make sure
there's an offer for our most
disadvantaged young children that they
do attend a provision where they can get
really good support but equally it's
involving the wider partnership like
Health visitors Etc as well just to make
though those processes really right that
that early identification
um you know really really strong as well
is there anything you want to answer
well it's just going to say I suppose
linking with the back to the TTT and the
traffic team together you know that work
is really well focused I suppose I'm
picking up those those families
um well it's it's directed more by the
school I suppose together you know the
sensitive children with their free
School meals so it will naturally I
think pick those most disadvantaged I
think the other bit that strategically
we've got a lot better at and you know
you'll love this is our handle on data
and our grip on data so we have much
more regular
um uh kind of data reports from our
performance team which highlight
um the needs coming through the system
um I think it's helpful when we do our
drugs and Joint strategic needs
assessment we can see those Trends and
again
um you know that's really important
um and I think as well you you know the
we're actually got some cluster senkos
that we have found funding to
um to pull together so these are senkos
who from really effective schools who
are incredibly inclusive and whose
outcomes for children with additional
needs are really strong who can do some
targeted work with some of our schools
where perhaps we we are more concerned
we're creating inclusion profiles
actually
um and is that what you're going to say
that so every school at the moment I'm
collecting attendance data uh percentage
of children who are vulnerable known to
social care etc etc and children with
scn so we can really see what the
outcomes are like because there will be
schools in Trafford who are doing a
really good good job in meeting our
children's needs and those who aren't as
as perhaps equipped to do that so we can
do some bespoke peer-to-peer support as
well for those schools
just on the data point what we're also
doing as well as
um strengthening our use of of data and
moving towards being data intelligent is
actually the capture of data from our
partners so particularly our health
colleagues So currently at the moment
comes data for example is reported
against the the generic population of of
children and new people access incomes
they don't specifically record on
children with send needs that access
comes and and I don't just mean from a
diagnosis perspective in terms of
ongoing support it's really important
that we work with our partners to get
that richness of data capture and to
understand need across all of the
dimensions rather than just what we have
from a local Authority point of view in
a timeliness point of view to to help
think about
actually all the strategies that we've
got in place the right strategies and
actually do we do we really understand
what that data is telling us to be data
intelligent rather than just data rich
thank you um councilor Ennis
thank you thanks again for for the
report and thank you for all the visuals
and I'm a visual learner so I appreciate
you
um so uh in terms of the uh you
mentioned at the top there about the the
financial pressures that schools are
under at the moment and uh the
government's done a pay deal on support
workers the effect support workers I
should say uh they've not funded it
though
um and schools are having to bridge that
Gap from their own budget
so I would like to know is that leading
in your view to schools paying the new
rate but for Less hours is that
affecting Frontline provision in that
way and how does that sit within the
wider pressures that you've talked about
when the number of uh children need in
an EHC plan is up significantly since
2019. yeah so that's a really good
question and and I think you're right
certainly those financial pressures are
having a huge impact on schools in terms
of how they can employ support
assistance where that's required to
particularly support children with with
scnd
um and with additional needs
um and equally Trafford is one of the
F40 group it's one of the lowest 40 uh
funded
um local authorities in terms of
education budget so it it is a
significant pressure
um I think in some respects that's where
the inclusion profiles will help because
we'll be able to see actually where
those High numbers of children with scnd
are and and what that means financially
for them
um I mean you know what we are hearing
from school certainly is you know the
challenge to recruit but equally
um you know the actual challenge to find
people who who who can be recruited to
support children with additional needs
um it's something that we will continue
to work with schools on I think the most
important for us is important thing for
us in light of these Financial pressures
is to try and Empower schools and
develop the capacity of them to to meet
these additional needs without
necessarily the need for additional for
additional staff
um but certainly it is a challenge we
are looking as well in some of our
strategic planning and directions in
terms of how we can put
um some additional resource into schools
so for example under the short break
work that we we've progressed following
one of the leaps in terms of actually if
schools wanted to be a provider of short
break whether that was on a one-to-one
or a group based basis whether we can
top slice some of our budget to give to
schools to help with some of those
funding pressures because if they've got
the staff that know the children that
understand their needs and they've got
the facilities within schools why would
we not look to them to provide an
activity-based offer and a number of our
schools already do but it's whether we
can use some of our existing budgets in
in a different way similarly with some
of the pressures in terms of home to
school transport whether actually
there's a conversation to be had
strategically with our schools around
whether they could assist with some of
that and again passport some of the cash
in but as Karen said it's not just about
the the budget being available it is
about
um the skills and people being
um people with the skills being employed
as well so there are some real pressures
obviously as well
um in terms of um some of the the high
needs block there is a Top-Up amount
that goes to schools and we're seeing
some of that pressure and we're doing
some analysis in terms of the the Top-Up
funding how that's being utilized
um and whether that is is matching need
and the skills that are required
I think what we are seeing is a higher
number of requests for the highest
Top-Up funding so we are seeing that
although schools need to evidence that
through provision mapping so we can make
a really clear and transparent decision
but we are seeing that and and you know
we are sometimes hearing schools say we
cannot we cannot meet need
um and you know that is that is a
challenge for us because you know we
really need to make our ambition is for
children to be with additional needs to
be educated in the local area at their
local school
um so this is this is some of the
challenges that we are getting and
hearing back from schools but even our
special schools are really struggling
financially as well
um so
um absolutely right it is an ongoing
pressure but for me you know this is
absolutely about making sure that we we
share the most effective practice and we
find ways to really support
um the workforce in in terms of their
own professional development
thank you are there any more questions
uh counselors please yes about I wanted
to ask
um
[Music]
I think that's an area that we've got
some work to do on when we're talking
about some of the work at the
development day and with the HC team
again we've been looking at some other
models there was a big Northwest event
recently where we're looking at what
good looks like within plans and it's
very interesting because it was about
100 people turned up a whole obviously
Keen to bringing their own plans and
Keen to know what everybody else thought
a good plan actually looked like and
co-production was a real theme there I
think there was some good practice in
Liverpool particularly that quite a few
of us jumped on and asked about and it
was about getting the co-production
meeting in to the the time scale and
again that's why we're keen to try and
move our Terminus a bit further forwards
we've got more time for that
co-production
I think we've been getting the children
and young people's and parents views at
the beginning and then we send the draft
and we're waiting for comments we've
been Reliant quite a lot on the EPC
educational psychologists at the moment
do
um well the core team particularly do a
really good job of co-producing outcomes
in their plan in their reports that feed
into the plan with the parent and the
school but we're not necessarily getting
everybody else together at the right
time I think to to be able to to build
that that's about individual
co-production of individual EHC plans I
mean there so I think we've got you know
we know that that's in our ambition plan
and we want to move that forward and and
getting feedback on a
every plan as well because at the moment
we don't ask for the parent feedback in
a formal way that we can again use data
you know look at
um we were Reliant then on feedback via
either complaints or
nice comment you know compliments or
through the parent Forum so I think we
need a more systematic way of getting
that feedback on every plan and the same
with annual reviews we did do it for a
while in the past and then it you know
it's it needs
um confirming and kind of using more
regularly I think the communication
engagement group though is really clear
about you know the co-production charter
and just making sure that we absolutely
are committed to the ladder of
co-production in every bit of work we do
and I think we probably go up and down
that ladder depending on um certain
pieces of work but I think what I would
like to think is from
um from certainly from Trafford parent
care reform there's a real commitment
for us to to really listen Jill and I
have very recently attended a couple of
the um Community groups that
um operate at some at some Matthews
Community Center and and again we've
we've kind of whizzed around the room
hearing those those stories we have
um our family information service
attends chatty Caffey which again is a
perfect opportunity to to really listen
to to some of the themes and and one
thing that we are trying to do is make
sure that that Trafford parent care
reform are represented not just on sun
groups but wider groups across the
council so again it's really making sure
that they can influence and and
challenge Us in the delivery of services
I think there's a couple of bits I'd
want to add to that
um we do recognize and know that at
times parents um confidence in the
service has been impacted by things like
delays whether it's delays in issuing
ehcps whether it's delays in terms of
formal diagnosis from a particular
service or or not
um so part of the the genuine strategic
approach is one to listen but two to act
on on what we're being told so Karen
already touched on the the leap panels
so the lived experience advisory panels
and they have been painful and they have
been difficult to hear some of those
messages but it's right that we listen
to that it's right that we say actually
this is what we're going to do together
and we need your help with it so that
genuine strategic intent to have a send
partnership that puts parent carers as
not just a stakeholder but a strategic
decision maker with that sharing of
responsibility is it's not going to be
achieved quickly and we're looking at a
time scale of September for for that
um in terms of actually progressing and
making that happen and having those um
real conditions of success I think the
other bit is to recognize that actually
for some parents and carers a formal
forum is absolutely the the right the
right way that they want to engage be
communicated with book for other people
and thinking about some of our
disadvantaged families that might be a
comfortable space and it might be the
way that they would want to engage so we
we're really looking at that stretch in
terms of how can we reach into our
communities how we can think about some
of our ethnically diverse communities to
hear their voice to act upon it so in
terms of that ladder of co-production
Are We There no we're not
um sometimes co-production I think is an
overused word because genuine
co-production means starting with a
blank sheet whereas quite often it's
more about co-design because there are
some parameters around it but even
having that open dialogue and that
conversation about this is the art of
the possible just like with children and
young people you know it it is
um
complex and and it genuinely means if
we're to co-produce something that we
have to give something up in order for
that to to go forward so
um continue to be work in progress
I just had one of the questions was
about the equality Assurance which
you've touched upon you've got quite
strong ideas for Quality shirts up to
the point of the plan being done but in
that first 12 months is there any
quality assurance before the review at
12 months to check that the plan is
actually being implemented correctly
and I suppose less from
um
in a systematic way but our schools are
expected to have you know to touch base
So within the code of practice the
schools are expected to have
um a review on a timely basis now that
might you know might be alongside
parents evening in some schools but it's
they're meant to have activity contact
so I suppose from our point of view of
actually checking the quality of what's
going on within the plan our duty is the
annual review we do have services that
are involved you know schools will bring
other services in like I was in advisory
service in between if they need further
support and advice
um but I would say our quality assurance
is more our annual reviews and we need
to bring the annual review Into the QA
framework properly as well does that
sound okay thank you Council Acton yeah
mine's probably just a comment really
because here it kind of concerned me
when my colleague here mentioned about
funding
across the board in in schools
um and you know the answer basically
some schools
um we can't provide the need required
and it it is worrying that it comes to
that because a lot of the delivery of
um special needs education is obviously
through the schools and so it's just a
comment I don't expect you to answer
that
I mean
sorry just um for committee's interest
and there is a lobbying meeting
happening at National level in September
and Trafford Council
um through the leadership is going to be
represented at that meeting because I
think you point councilor Acton that we
might not be able to directly turn that
around but it is something that is of
national concern it's something that is
a priority in terms of the association
of directors of children's services
um because it it whilst some of our
schools are saying that whilst we've got
a deficit recovery plan in terms of our
high needs deficit we are by no means
the the worst in the country one of our
neighboring local authorities their
predicted deficit in three years time
will be in excess of a 100 million so
it's right that we have that lobbying at
that National level to to try and make
sure that issues about actually if you
want schools to be inclusive if you want
them to to deliver this you can't ask
them to pay for their the the increase
of pay Rises out of an already burdened
budget and I don't think that's a
political statement I think that's about
demand and Supply in terms of it so it's
right that we put that context back to
the policy makers yeah and the
recruitment problems yeah the
recruitment problems as well you know so
it all goes together doesn't it
I I think just you know
um our schools are absolutely fantastic
in Trafford and I am so so proud of them
um and you know the way that they really
do work in partnership with us to to
Really support some of our most
vulnerable I I would never want that
kind of taken away from them either
um you know we've got an inclusion
collaborative that we're setting up
which has school Representatives on it
and that is absolutely about how we can
enable them to to be as to be helped to
be as supportive and inclusive as
possible
um Jill mentioned that the DSG deficit
recovery plan that we've got to submit
to DFE at the end of this week and that
is absolutely about how we're going to
address the pressures in the high needs
budget which is where the sand spend is
um and we have to come up with some
options and and you know part of those
options is absolutely around investor
save really about how we can support and
incentivize schools to to to really meet
children's needs as best they can so
that they can attend their local school
and live and stay and be educated in
their local area so it is something that
we are committed to and schools
absolutely will do everything that they
can but sometimes you know that there we
know a lot of our schools are overpan
now because we've had such an influx of
of new children into the borough
um which is fabulous you know that's
real credit to our schools but it again
that's adding some of the pressures and
these are some of the reasons why
they're just struggling to actually meet
some of the more complex needs of our
children in in Borough
one of the things in terms of the recent
external Assurance work that we engaged
with one of the things that came out
really well and really positively was
the quality of sand support and the
sense support is happening within within
our schools so you know whilst there
there might be pressures and whilst
there might be a level of complexity
that schools are saying well actually
within a class of of 30 pupils can I
meet this level of complexity there
there is real strong support for our
children and our sense support and that
is happening within our schools came out
really well from that exercise
thank you and thank you for for the
report
um oh sorry Council Proctor thank you
I've been I've been listening and
reflecting and this
something I don't know if you can
provide this information I was
reflecting back on the children we
fostered
and the percentage of those children who
had special educational needs and
that it was a significant percentage
have you any way of documenting that
with our 400 odd looks after children
yeah I mean certainly the the virtual
school
um so Lindsay
um absolutely has has a handle on that
date although I think Pamela's just
quoted the number
the first question
um that um I was looking at partner was
it we've got 362 cared for children at
the moment we have seen numbers come
down but we've experienced a recent
spike in terms of that over
representation of children within the
cared for system that have send needs it
is a discrete area of work because we do
recognize that over representation
um and we
use our electronic database systems to
flag the numbers
um and it's something that's in our uh
send self-assessment I can't quite
recall what the percentage is
saying it's 22 so I'll Trust my
colleague in in terms of that but I
think it's a point well well made and
again critically If you experience a
level of disadvantage by virtue of your
life experience and your early life
experiences living in a an environment
that doesn't allow you to flourish and
grow and then you have additional
learning needs whatever that learning
need is it's really important that we go
even further to overcome both of those
issues and to support in the right way
long-winded way of saying one of one of
the pieces of work that we are really
focused on is trying to make we will
never get to a point where we have a
single plan because statutory we're
required to have different plans whether
you looked after we're required to have
an EHC plan but to put the child in the
center and really think about children's
needs on a holistic basis is one of the
the areas of all Collective ambition
work that we're working on
I think as well the virtual school
um Lindsay has has a dedicated senko if
you like that acts for for those and
advocates for those children with
additional needs who who may be looked
after and has actually created a really
strong almost therapeutic team around
some of these children so speech in
language play therapists dedicated
educational psychologists so there's a
real commitment I think to to supporting
the most vulnerable children
and
I was just going to say I'm on Workforce
Development we're linking up so with um
you know the inclusion collaborative
that Karen mentioned we're looking at
the schools that have signed up to
inclusion Charter what areas they're
identifying but we've got virtual school
on there we're looking at that overlap
especially around emotional needs so the
the trauma informed training work that
they're doing with Virtual School we're
making sure that's linking up with our
emotionally basic school non-attendance
work and
UMR work around children with
neurodiversity because the
neurodivergent children because there's
something overlap but we want to be
careful with schools as well and Link in
with those inclusion profiles to make
sure that we know
um you know what training people have
had and how that overlaps and
and just to come back to that Workforce
Development point one of the real
successes that we've seen over the last
Academic Year is the engagement of our
parent carer Forum in terms of teaching
and supporting our school Workforce
through the autism in schools program
um and that has got such positive
feedback in terms of bringing that lived
experience into the the Workforce
Development space
thank you thank you for the reports
um and
as usual very reassuring
um I'm always very impressed with how
easily you were able to give answers to
these questions and thank you to members
of the committee for their questions
um I'm going to move on to item 10 which
is the draft work program for the
current year we did meet online we have
a teams meeting it's a few weeks ago now
I think and I know some of you members
um attended so we've got down for the
September meeting and people concerned
about transition so we'd split that into
two
um so transition four children in care
and transition for children with ehcps
um if there are any topics that any
members at any time feel they'd like to
add to the work program
um obviously if there's a burning issue
that comes up at some point within the
borough or nationally we can always
um I try and keep limit the reports
because they are lengthy reports
um so try and sort of we try and have an
education item or a social care item
um but you know if there's anything
anybody thinks of this is open to change
throughout the year
councilor Sutton
um yes one suggestion since that uh
team's meeting uh that I've been mulling
over
um I mean I've lost count of how many
times we've heard the phrase post
pandemic or post covered uh this evening
it's it's the consistency through
everything whenever we start looking at
data we're looking at 2022 and thinking
is this back to normal uh inverted
commas normal uh but that's just looking
at the data of the the kind of items
that we're talking about this evening
but uh also for example in the health
and safety report that went to full
Council last week the uh injuries to
school staff because we've noticed
notably higher
um in 2022
um but then I'm also aware of uh as this
school year has come to a conclusion
it's been the first year without any
type of covid interruptions or uh
restrictions uh discussions amongst Ted
teachers and slts uh from across
different schools about how
example children's
[Music]
regulated behavior and uh poorer
self-regulation behavior and it's
there's a a lot of
um low lower level evidence of an
undercurrent of how these children have
been affected uh and their different age
cohorts of course
um and there's
there's that um qualitative data that
um is easily missed and also the threads
through
um the quantitative stuff uh that we
have available uh about
uh where things are truly going back to
like they were in 2019 and where there's
evidence of particular cohorts being
affected in a way that is ongoing
um uh and just to really put that in
context we were talking about the
transitions several times that it was
bear in mind it was those whose year six
uh a year with all of that preparation
transition was the one most disrupted
they're now entering year 10 those
effects in key stage one are now into
the top end preparing for their
transition and those uh children born in
lockdown of approaching Nursery age and
why pretending anybody who says that
they're too young to be affected
um I just I don't know how this
committee is placed to try and
um find a thread through where there is
evidence that it made it may then be be
suitable to support uh schools Council
uh uh uh departments and other agencies
in in what is upcoming for these
children
um sorry it's come across it kind of
ended up as a bit of a ramble but
um
uh I don't know how that could fit in
with this committee's role but I just
wanted to raise it as something that we
really need to consider
so it was that kind of
just a surprise
that you want to understand like which
areas of like a child's life are they
are you seeing the longest on running
effects of covid was that oh like you're
on like looking at different stages see
where the the impact is still being felt
and other areas where it's not being
felt quite so much
yeah I mean the starting point might be
to set out to get a snapshot of how
those different cohorts are currently
showing they've been impacted at this
point three years on uh and then from
that maybe something to them look at and
review
um I don't know if there's anything I
think some of the data that we hold in
terms of possibly the impact obviously
we've got performance data that we can
share and we can you know have a look at
some comparisons although you know
certainly ofsted wouldn't want us to do
that because they're really clear that
they're not comparable but we can
certainly kind of show that and any
Trends within that we can share
attendance rates we can share exclusion
rates suspension rates
um certainly those sorts of things
um and and there may be information from
from all of our schools have a quality
assurance visit as well annulene there
may be some information from those forms
that we can pull together as well as to
what schools are telling us
um yeah so in that situation maybe it's
something that could be included with
that is specifically asking schools for
what they've noticed about any
particular age cohorts and differences
from what the the equivalent cohort
three years ago
um and to be able to just capture that
information because so much of it exists
in out there in WhatsApp chats or
whatever it doesn't actually make it
through to to being used to support
children and if it's certainly informing
their strategic development plans you
know we we will see that so that there
may be something that we can pull
together around that if that will be
helpful
okay thanks Alex did you want it uh yeah
just
Gathering what you're saying about
finding the Common Thread might it be
rather than that's something that's a
specific item if that's like something
that the committee could request is
covered within like every report like a
little subsection around like the
ongoing impacts of covet uh like on that
element of the service so like it's
continuously referenced so you can see
that thread of like the ongoing impacts
of Provident you can include some of the
data that you have something like that
um I do have a slight nervousness not
least because
um we don't really understand
post-pandemic recovery and if we look at
things like the National Audit office
um report saying that actually it'll
take 10 years to to get to catch up
stage
um and and
actually it is interconnected and into
into relational issues so to actually
say actually we've seen an increase in
semh presentations and we're putting
that down to the pandemic I I think it
would be a brave person that made that
correlation
um I think we could say that um some of
our our working hypotheses might be some
of this is post-covered impact but it
would only be a hypothesis I think it's
a much cleverer more scientific person
than me that would be able to make such
correlations and and assumptions
I do think though that we can't
underestimate some of
that the experience that adults and
children have had as a consequence of
covid the pandemic I don't think we can
underestimate what that means for need
and demand really I just wonder if it's
something that that we give a little bit
more teasing out to what the specifics
that that we wanted to use I also having
said that I'm not sure we can make
direct correlations in terms of things
um yeah I absolutely agree about not
making direct correlations and I was
more thinking about where there's that
that of course with evidence of
something being known to be different or
perceived to be different
um just capturing that so that we can
then be looked at by those people who
actually understand the uh the the
impact of that kind of societal trauma
um that
um if we don't actually capture it in
the first place it's it's and is missed
um so I don't know whether it could be
something not necessarily asking
specifically
covered related or things as a
consequence of covert but maybe
observations of differences between now
and pre pre-pandemics something like
that that's a bit more neutral just to
in reports to try and record
I kind of I understand where you're
coming from completely I think it would
be difficult because we have no marker
at the beginning when life was normal
um and in some respects I don't think
we'd ever get back to that same normal
so it's what what are you comparing I
mean I noticed
um you know during our camps task and
finish work we that was a measurable
increase in the amount of referrals
um we have got school absence on the
November agenda here that is something
that we can measure because we've got
the facts but I think it's such a broad
umbrella and you know as somebody just
mentioned it could be 10 years until we
see the full impact for all of us adults
and from Tiny Tots upwards so yeah
perhaps it is something we're perhaps
teased out and where we have got facts
we can possibly improve but yeah
[Music]
um
no there was no going back to normal
we're in a different normal now and
that's
um that's why I'm referring to these go
whatever age these children have been
affected
um that is part of their development now
for uh that is that is a simple matter
of fact and they are a unique generation
uh as a result of that very
unfortunately
um
it's just I wanted to open up yes maybe
it's not a specific item but it's maybe
someone who can go and think about and
perhaps discuss separately outside of
yeah outside of meetings and obviously
anybody wants to participant on that I
just thought it's just the way all
variables not just tonight's
everything's so referring to this first
lot of post-pandemic data etc etc uh but
with children there's you can't wait for
another year to see whether it's to come
back to 2019 levels because Mr yeah all
right thank you so I've got counselor
Ennis and then councilor but
thank you and apologies uh chair I
missed the uh Zoom meeting that was set
up to talk about the work program
initially I'm going to put that down to
the email problems I had straight after
the um local elections
um so apologies for that
um we've a growing number of migrants
and refugees in Trafford and it's
something that's really really welcome
uh in my view
um I'm thinking about children from
Afghanistan Ukraine Sudan and Hong Kong
but not limited to those places but all
of these groups have uh but potentially
represent
um challenges that relate to the work of
this committee and just maybe it is a
thread that goes through
um the whole body of work that the
committee undertakes over the course of
the year but it would potentially be
something that we could see in in the
work program singled out as well so just
to raise that issue which I didn't get
the chance to do yeah at the appropriate
times we did look at this last year
during the last Municipal year we we did
look at that so the report is
um available online it should it will be
won't it I don't think it was the March
meeting it might have been the I had one
January and one in February didn't we so
certainly at one of those meetings but
it might be worth something that we
could revisit in the future Maybe
features for an update on how these
children and young people are settling
in into the various communities so
that's maybe something we call keeper
watching brief on
um as time goes by if that's okay yeah
yeah any oh sorry cancel a book actually
it was just following on from the
previous uh conversation we were having
you know about the the the
possible covert situation I mean I know
there's a significant long-term sickness
amongst the general population and uh in
terms of children young people I I know
it's difficult to analyze whether it's a
covered related issue or not but it is a
where you've got uh the reports it's
more very much on what people are saying
whether you know they feel as if it's
like covered related so is that the kind
of uh
um thing that sort of come through
uh we I mean you know in terms of
um young people I suppose there may be
Public Health that can provide some some
statistics on on that
um there may be something around where
non-attendance
um at schools you know what the reasons
for whether it has been health related
or if it is something that is more
emotionally based
um there may be something that we can
produce our Sally
um so we did establish a long covid
group as well which was all age so we
looked at adults and children's and
established a pathway for children's who
were diagnosed with long covered and so
you're more than happy to share some
information around that the numbers are
very very small but we do know that some
children have been heavily affected with
Co of it since having covered and it's
changed their life costs completely and
obviously the impact on their family
unit as well and carers and so yeah we
can share that
yeah yeah would that be an onerous task
for you to pull that data for us
I'm just wondering if or if you could
send it maybe you could look at it as
part of the school absence that we're
covering in November or if it's
something the committee would just like
to have a look at just out of interest
for the figures and if you could send it
as if you've got that yeah
that would be interesting um it might
not necessarily be in a table and
projected in a lovely line graph or
anything but I'll do my best to try and
pull it together so there's some
narrative around it as well but in terms
of what um what you're saying around the
presenting need since covid we we don't
know the impact as such and the numbers
we're seeing if they are down to covert
itself
um I still said but
you know some of the presenting needs
that we're seeing are different and the
level of need that we're seeing is
different and far more Acuity in terms
of presentation comorbidity you have
children so you know it's we can
understand that it's going to have some
impact but again it's it's around
specific to what they've been through
during the pandemic
and I can say that from a health point
of view because Health has been
obviously heavily impacted by Children's
Health been heavily impacted by the
pandemic
thank you everybody I'm not aware of any
oh sorry Emma sorry
[Music]
yeah um in terms of uh both the comments
on covid and uh Refugee and Asylum
seeking children I think there's room
for that to be discussed in the next
meeting when we look at transitions
um I'm very aware that lots of children
have been dispersed to Trafford over the
past couple of years and the company of
Silence weeks and they'll be reaching
adulthood quite soon because of their
age and what plans we've got for them
will be really good to hear uh similar
with covid while it's very hard to
assess things that do take a long time
for us to fully understand things like
how service provision has changed
um with transition you know services
that we've lost for instance or gained
through covid will be really good to
know about when we look at transitions
for children in care but I also wanted
to ask in the sort of spirit of
co-production and young people's voice
whether that could be included in those
reports that you know um that we find
out what they think about transitions
I think it would be really helpful in
terms of not not
um taking up a whole day in terms of the
reports and the information that that we
could provide in terms of some of the
specifics of transitions
for children in care or transitions for
children with ehcp is potentially a
really really broad set of service areas
and I think you've asked very clearly
um counselor there about some specific
issues
um and
um whilst we have had a number of
unaccompanied Asylum seeking miners
um coming into the borough we're
actually well below what are our
national expectation is
um so just in terms of prior to the
September committee some clarity around
what are the the real specifics that
that it would be of interest and of
useful was to present back to committee
would be hugely helpful for the teams
really
um
so not wanting to dodge a question or
the challenge but
um I I think we want to be as helpful as
possible to the committee to the areas
of interest and and Challenge and deep
dive that that would be of use
foreign
okay so is everybody as I say I'm not
aware of any urgent business so
um oh sorry I can't surprise I've got a
couple questions okay yeah
um
first of all
because I I haven't a clue do we do any
form of exit interviews for foster
carers who who retire
and what happens to that information
so we have a a monthly performance
meeting in my part of the service there
is um alternate monthly reports from the
head to service so we meet tomorrow and
I have a quarterly report from the head
of service from the fostered service
that information is included in that
report and we're taking that into
account in terms of the development of
the fostering modernization plan and it
also will be included in the annual
report of the fostering Service as well
which will come through to myself and
Jill great thank you and then sorry I
have to take my glasses off now
my other question is about co-opted
members we we don't have any we have
several vacancies yeah do we advertise
we do advertise don't we uh we used to
find it a lot easier we do advertise
every now and again we've got uh putting
through some uh advertisements at the
moment but it's um we used to have a
really good system where when we also
run the governance governance services
for schools because if you look at them
that one of the requirements is that
they're a governor at a traffic school
so for secondary school places that's
particularly tough because there's only
one
um I think there's only one school but
um
um yeah we do put out advertisements
every now and again and pretty much
every time we get no responses like I
always inform counselors and say if
you're a member of Governors and like
you're a travel school please do let
them know as well because we are
carrying those vacancies and but we'll
look into putting up yeah again
um further but we do it through I think
it's through a News Bulletin that we've
been doing in the last couple of times
but we usually do it via Governor's
Services which was more successful from
what we've been trying Alex just yeah
just we do have a an mou memorandum of
understanding We Trust yes who has got
the vast Monopoly if you like of
um uh our schools in Trafford so it's
the external Governor service provider
if you like so we we I could reach out
to Julie Lawson and and facilitate that
if that will be helpful
uh that'd be great thank you
thanks
okay so
um
all that's left for me to do is to close
the meeting thank you all for coming and
much appreciated
um hoping to have a nice August break
for all of us
um no meetings
um after this week so just wish you all
a safe journey home and enjoy your
summer
take care now